you know that was a song that goes like
why men great till they gotta be great
I've been singing a version of that in
my head but with different lyrics which
goes the world doesn't need your
coronavirus hot take anyway good morning
Hank it's Tuesday it's question Tuesday
the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters he's here isn't
he what should happen in the movie cats
- I want two things I want some of the
cats to be really big uh-huh something
that has to be really small I want one
thing which is for there not to be a
cat's - what was your first memory of me
of you of me I don't know they're not
chronological when we were kids one time
we were playing football like tackle
football and remember you hit a tree and
you got a concussion sure it was of a
size where when you hit it it been yeah
it moved significantly yeah all right so
I recently went to our childhood home is
the tree bigger it's not bigger Hank
it's the biggest tree in the world how
different would boxed cake directions be
on Mars
it's probably like a situation where you
don't need different instructions you
need a different cake mix you're gonna
have a lower pressure in the habit so
you have lower pressure higher oxygen
percentage sort of thing going on in
that case your cake would probably rise
very fast and very big and it would be
like a giant muffin turns out I did need
Hanks cake mix Mars hot cakes
I might be wrong oh I mean that's the
whole point of a hot take hey ah you
don't do your research first what either
do you ever consider another field of
creative writing like poetry ah I mean I
write poetry all the time precise show
tangents it's true it's a great podcast
and also i write podcasts like the
efficacy of youth is juicy fruit the one
with stripes or is that the yellow one
juicy fruit is the yellow one what's the
one with stripes called remember that as
a zebra as its mascot
oh yeah zebra gum can google do it can
google do it
fruit stripe that might be the most
succinct way of describing fruit stripe
gum I've ever heard though a strong but
fleeting flavor what did you think of
Hanks look a beautifully foolish
endeavor of which signed copies are
available for pre-order now I just
finished it it's so great like the last
look it seems impossible to me that it
was written by Hank you know what I mean
like it seems impossible that it was
written by my brother who's kind of a
doofus
so pre-order Hanks book we're going on
tour for it in July maybe hey on npr's
ask me another over the weekend you are
described as the modern-day Bronte
sisters how does that make you feel I
think it's extremely kind
oh yeah makes me way over the top way
over them the truth is either Hank or
myself would be lucky to be the Bronte
sisters NER do well brother Bramwell hey
Google who is the longest-lived of the
Bronte siblings
according to Charlotte Bronte the most
famous of the Bronte sisters died the
31st of March 1855 the one who lived the
longest and the sister who died first
were buried side by side in a crypt
located in the Hayworth Church but they
live forever in English literary history
not forever that's not how it works the
funniest part about that is that Google
is technically pronouncing the last name
correctly it was probably pronounced
Bronte hey we're saying we're all up
here being like Bronte because that's
how it's spelled
but Google is too smart for that
business have you seen any of the tick
talks about us about us yeah oh crap
Sarah sent me one today I haven't seen
any tick talks about us except for the
one that Sarah sent me and I probably
won't see any tick talks about me unless
they're like reported in the New York
Times because that's where I get my tick
tock here's gonna have to go to our show
here in Columbus Ohio tomorrow we'll be
in Indianapolis then we'll be in Ann
Arbor Michigan hope to see you lots of
you on tour Hank I'll see you right now
good job great outro